on peut donc encore entonné la
marseillaise à la fin d'un discours on
verra d'ailleurs si on peut qualifier on
en parlera tout à l'heure ce discours de
manuel valls de grands discours c'était
évidemment après les attentats mais
c'est peut-être la preuve que l'exercice
n'est pas mort à quoi bon voilà les
questions qu'on va se poser ses grands
discours aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il en
reste est ce que c'est encore adapté
dans un monde communication politique de
deux petites phrases et de réseaux
sociaux c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
de faire un discours en 140 signes bref
est ce que les français les attentes
encore on va en parler avec nos invités
avec j'ai mis à gérer jérémy roze est
décidément je vais réussir jérémy roze
l'auteur de ce documentaire avec
également alain duhamel membre de
l'académie des sciences morales et
politiques éditorialistes notamment à
rtl auteur d'une histoire personnelle de
la cinquième qui ressort chez points
sont en ce moment christian delporte
historien professeur à l'université de
versailles dont je signale les livres
histoire de la langue de bois et
histoire de la séduction en politique ça
recouvre quand même pas mal le discours
c'est publié chez flammarion et puis
gaël sliman qui lui désormais est à la
tête de l'institut de sondage au doxa
qui sont nos coeurs et nos reins ceux
des français et qui vous aviez signé
pompe il le pompier ou maçon c'était aux
éditions du moment sur la campagne de
2012 j'irai jérémy roze end à bord d'où
est venue l'idée de faire un
documentaire sur les grands discours
c'était une envie de faire un grand
documentaire historique
l'idée est venue surtout de se dire que
la parole politique aujourd'hui et quand
même fortement décriée et que nous
sommes issus d'une d'une dune d'une
tradition républicaine de la vème
république ou le grand discours a quand
même marqué les esprits et les grands
discours qu'on a choisi pour ce film
sont un peu comme les grands événements
qui secoue le monde on sait tous enfin
pour ceux qui étaient vivants envie
qu'ils étaient nés à l'époque où on
était au moment de ce grand discours là
est la marque d'un grand discours
pauvros et qu on se souvient du moment
précis où on l'a entendu la défense de
ce qu'on faisait à ce moment là comme
pour certains le 11 septembre voilà on
se souvient où on était une idée comme
ça où on se souvient jour où
sa frappe ou sa frappe le jour où
mitterrand par exemple le prononcer son
discours aux obsèques de bérégovoy on se
souvient je vous donne cette connerie il
y en a plein d'autres et donc l'idée
c'était de retracer un petit peu cette
vème république qui s'est écrite aussi
avec des grands discours et ses grands
discours évidemment subjectivement ont
été choisis comme des marqueurs de
l'histoire aussi oratoire de la vème
république mais c'est un art à bout de
souffle pour reprendre notre titre alors
c'est sûr que la période de
démonstration on a basculé dans la
communication et dans la pub sous
giscard on en discutera tout à l'heure
et canadiens même je sois qu'il est pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous mais
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
c'est perdu
perdu c'est difficile de le dire en tout
cas c'est sûr que les perspectives
qu'offre aujourd'hui
les technologies modernes à savoir les
réseaux sociaux
l'immédiateté aujourd'hui du discours
politique fait qu'on peut quand même se
poser la question à savoir si au delà
des campagnes présidentielles il ya
encore la place pour des grands discours
présidentiel mais le discours qui vous
aiment marquer vous celui que vous
retenez alors il y en a deux il ya celui
de deux chirac au vel d'hiv
parce que effectivement ils affrontent
quelque chose reconnaît la
responsabilité de la france dans la
déportation des comptes une histoire qui
était écrite et remet un petit peu les
choses à leur place
c'est incroyable c'est qu'on apprend au
passage que c'était pas du tout un
discours fait pour marquer l'histoire
non ce qui est le plus incroyable
documentaire je les ai découverts
c'était un discours alors c'est ce qu'on
devait faire explique dino christine
albanel a activement c'est un discours
protocolaire et donc comme un discours
protocolaire il n'a pas été relu par
tous et toutes les personnes enfin c'est
ce qu'elle n'est pas du tout je suis
persuadé que compte tenu de ils étaient
très conscients de ce que politiquement
ça implique et qui était d'ailleurs tout
à fait à son honneur enfin il changer le
regard officielle de la france sur ce
qu'elle avait été pendant vichy et il
rompait avec à la fois de gaulle et
mitterrand là dessus donc je crois pas
un instant qu'il ait pu le prononcer
l'ayant leur lui avançant sans se rendre
compte du poids historique de ce qu'ils
disaient oh non non tu te rendes compte
force certainement par contre qu'il
serait un choix il n'y a pas été passés
au crible d'autres qui le sont
d'habitude ne lui parle plus mais pour
ça qu'ils étaient meilleurs sans doute
dominique de villepin qui était l'autre
plume appréciera et secrétaire général
de l'union et puis surtout aux six mois
le discours de mitterrand
que j'aime beaucoup c'est le dernier
discours public qui prononce au
parlement européen
parce qu'à ce moment là au delà de
de l'éloquence du mourant on pourrait
dire de la personne qui libéré un petit
peu de tout l'est de tous les carcans
c'est une vraie
c'est un vrai héritage qu'il transmet
c'est une vraie transmission de son
combat de son histoire personnelle
presque sur le ton de la conversation
des ja oui mais alors ça aussi on passe
un jour dire que c'est peut-être
travailler j'étais de ces techniques
quand moi je vais faire des dizaines de
discours il avait une façon de s'appuyer
avec le coup de gauche sur le pupitre
qui donnait à tous ceux qui étaient
devant lui l'impression que c'était à
chacun qui s'adressait et puis en plus
c'est vrai ce que vous dites fallait au
moment où il a prononcé ce discours la
quête un discours superbe il n'avait
plus de surmoi rien il dit disait
vraiment tout ce qu'ils avaient à
l'esprit donc ce sont vos deux discours
préféré un leu leu leu +1 le plus
important pour vous après c'est vrai
aussi que c'est une question de
génération 4 âge voilà c'est ça c'est à
dire le maire n'aime absolument c'est à
dire que c'est le discours qu'on a
entendu qu'on avait vécu en direct aux
accords ex alain duhamel ce qui fait un
grand discours c'est la phrase le moment
ce qui fait un grand discours ce c'est
le moment c'est à dire que un grand
discours n'est pas toujours un grand
discours avant d'avoir été prononcés les
quelques fois mais il ne l'est pas
forcément
et pas toujours très mais non si c'est
toujours prémédité est ce que
l'inspiration le talent
la mise en scène et l'effet produit vont
forcément coïncider non il ya des grands
discours qui tombent à plat ou qui
passent inaperçues en exemple aux beaux
jours des as lors des discours brillant
qui passent inaperçus
sur par exemple au politique étrangère
je pense qu'il peut y avoir donc pendant
un quinquennat au moins cinq ou six
grands discours auquel personne neutre
ne prête attention donc c'est une
question de moment
à la fois une question de fond il faut
une vision il faut une rupture il faut
se projeter semble dans l'avenir il ya
une autre question de forme il faut
d'émotion et l'émotion elle passe par
les images que l'on va nourrir dans dont
on va nourrir le discours mais également
par la personnalité parle-t-on par le
geste par le regard de celui qui
prononce le discours puis le discours au
fond parce que il pour qu'il reste il
faut d'abord qu'ils passent par le
filtre des médias il faut qu'il y ait
derrière derrière ça une formule
côtoient titre au disque ou maintenant
c'est à dire à partir du moment où ce
qui l'essentiel du discours est ce qui
en sera retenu quelquefois sous forme de
2015 dans le 20 heures le soir et à ce
moment là effectivement le regard c'est
est ce qu'il ya un moment fort
correspondant à une émotion collective
ou pas avec et comme vous disiez juste
titre avec la nécessité d'une rupture ce
quelque chose pour qu'ils aient une
dramatisation mais avant a avancé ce
filtre de la télévision d'aujourd'hui
même quand les discours étaient déjà
retransmis à la télévision avant c'était
le discours lui même en tant qu'objet
qui avait sa propre logique maintenant
ça finit par être la reprise du discours
et non plus le discours mais ça c'est
quand même mis en place petit à petit
j'ai commencé votre documentaire avec je
vous ai compris c'est une formule mais
c'est nous et ont bien sûr il faut
toujours une formule mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que avant le discours
lui-même par exemple celui du 13 mai
c'est un c'est à un objet construit et
qui est consommer si j'ose dire dans son
ensemble et qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
grands discours mais kiki dont on
retient les 2 minutes 15
dans les grandes grandes circonstances
qui passe dans le 20h et donc qui est
forcément réduit c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça face à ces jeux c'est le contenu du
document c'est pour ça qu'on peut
s'interroger non pas sur le fait de
savoir s'il reste de grands orateurs
bien sur le fait de savoir s'il peut y
avoir de grands discours c'est la
question qui va se poser si le discours
politique c'est pas appauvri d'une
certaine manière vous parliez de
transmission par les médias vous donner
dans votre documentaire un exemple qui
est frappant qui est expliquée par le
journaliste christophe barbier c'est le
discours de du général de gaulle à la
république en 1958 les images de 58
elles sont formidables parce que on a
pour la première fois une scénographie
grandiose mais pas seulement pour ceux
qui sont sur la place pour ceux qui vont
voir les images à la télé ou dans les
actualités cinématographiques et là on
voit bien que la vème république ça va
être l'air de l'art oratoire adapté à la
télévision
oui donc le grand v qui reprend le v de
la victoire mais c'est aussi levé le
chiffre 5 en chiffres romains levet qui
est aussi lever des bras levés du
général de gaulle donc toute
l'iconographie se met en place pour que
le discours soit appuyé sur des images
est donc le grand discours rentrer dans
la petite lucarne et en rentant dans la
petite lucarne ils ne diminuent pas il
se démultiplie et ça ça c'est la
cinquième république les codes de la
communication finalement la cinquième
république elle est moderne dès le début
oui surtout quelle suite compris qu'il
fallait utiliser la télévision les
discours qui il voyage beaucoup en
province si je suis beaucoup de discours
qui sont faits des copier coller des
précédents ai dit à quel point les
bretons sont formidables les nordistes
le sont aussi les provinces aux
provençaux sont le grand avenir de la
france très important parce qu'on a
reproché à nicolas sarkozy de faire du
copier coller dans ses discours vous me
dites de golf hôtel ça alors oui tout à
fait
de relire tous ces discours
ressemble tous les uns aux autres mais
ce que l'on retient finalement des
grands discours ce sont les allocutions
du général de gaulle c'est le discours
moment du putsch des généraux et ça
passe par la télévision mais mais s'il
est vrai que le général de gaulle
immédiatement à inventer et inventer
incarner un type de communication
complètement différent c'était lui et
lui seul parce que les autres discours
qui voulait être grand au début de la
vème république n'avait absolument pas
ses caractéristiques là c'était le
monopole du général c'est lui qui savait
faire ça c'est sa marque oui atteint
devient une marque jusqu'à après
d'autant qu'il avait le monopole des
allocutions télévisées oui bien sûr bien
sûr mais je pense à cette époque là il y
avait des discours qui était ambitieux
pierre michel debré prononcer des
discours ambitieux quand ils sont
malades mais non non on va rester dans
l'histoire jérémy roze n vous êtes mené
la dent dure et giscard non car
visiblement avec giscard on passe un
nouveau cap et on passe de la com à la
pub c'est vrai que c'est un passage
particulier déjà une question de
génération giscard a pas du tout et pas
du tout issus de la même génération que
que son prédécesseur que ce soit
pompidou ou de gaulle
et il ya peut-être une question de
culture à ce moment là qu'on voit
peut-être beaucoup plus aujourd'hui les
de culture et d'éducation c'est à dire
que ce qui a nourri intellectuellement à
de gaulle pompidou est très différent de
ce qu'on nourrit aujourd'hui je pense au
niveau de la littérature par exemple sur
tout ce qui a pu nourrir les
ce
qui est du coup ça se ressent forcément
dans leur personnalité ça se ressent
forcément dans le discours qui vont
prononcer avec giscard il la télévision
comme on viens de l'entendre dans
l'extrait précédent de christophe
barbier à sa place est prise c'est à
dire à l'époque de 58 jacques 30% je
pars à 40% maximum de français qui ont
la télévision avec giscard je pense
qu'on est déjà passé à une majorité de
français qui ont la télévision et donc
il ya des techniques effectivement
politiques qui sont importées des états
unis
qui ont beaucoup servi à giscard ce
qu'il veut pas dire que c'était un
mauvais président ce qui veut dire en
tout cas qu'on en retient peut-être pas
on retient plus un style on retient plus
une intelligence de giscard et on
retient pas forcément un une éloquence
une grande éloquence des grands discours
peut-être parce qu'il a été peu trop
trop pédagogie pour formater formaté je
sais pas mais en tout cas il a voulu
tout le temps expliqué ce qu'il faisait
et c'est peut-être ça qui est pas bien
passé alors je vois pas du tout les
choses de cette manière là d'abord
giscard avait été un grand orateur
parlementaire ce qu'on a oublié avant
d'être président quand il était à
l'assemblée y prononcer ce qu'on
appelait vraiment des grands discours
est alors en particulier quand il était
ministre des finances son numéro annuel
sur la loi de finances et des célèbres
c'est vrai mais c'est la rentrée dans
les épaules et mat et professionnels le
gars sur sa classe ça correspond tout à
fait à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure où
le délire lorsque vous disiez c'est à
dire encore faut-il qu'ils aient le
moment la rupture le symbole
l'affectivité et c'est bon donc ils
avaient les capacités d'être en tout cas
un grand orateur mais ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il est le premier des
présidents à être devenu plutôt qu'un
grand orateur un intervenant à la
télévision alors là il s'agit pas
simplement des extraits de discours qui
survivaient surnage le soir dans le 20h
il s'agit de sa participation à des
émissions qu'il veut qu'il prépare et
oui alors là même type d'expression qui
n'a plus rien à voir évidemment avec le
discours et braderie le disait quoi
l'émission télévisée et puis c'est plus
de la rhétorique où est la seule chose
c'est que je suis lui a été
extraordinairement préparer autrement
dit c'était c'était la poursuite du
discours par d'autres moyens c'était la
réponse à des questions
bon mais mais c'était effectivement un
autre moment alors dans le document que
je trouve dans son ensemble excellent je
trouve que le passage sur giscard et
quand même tellement ironique par
rapport à la réalité du personnage on
n'en voit que les ridicules c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui a pas mal changé la
société pendant deux ans et qui sur le
plan international a une stature qui
était en tout cas respecté j'avais mis
rosen chercher des grands discours
oui c'était pas une pas une histoire
complète je dirais que là ça faisait un
petit temps vous l'avez trouvé injuste
alors je trouve pas que ce soit un petit
homme il ya eu des grands discours de
françois hollande et de nicolas sarkozy
parce que vous n'en trouvez pas visible
pas que j'en trouve pas c'est que je
pense qu'en tout cas pour françois
hollande encore plus on a on manque de
recul pour pour le savoir ils peuvent
encore prononcé des grands discours où
est ce qu'ils ont perdu vous disiez tout
à l'heure ils n'ont pas forcément la
culture du grand discours ils n'ont pas
la culture stylistique rhétorique
peut-être caves et les grands les
présidents qui les ont précédés et qui
ont fourni dans le col dans l'imaginaire
collectif des français un style qu'on
aime bien entendre ce qui est par
exemple a très bien marché avec le
discours de villepin à l'onu où les
français ont réentendu à ce moment là
une geste très gaullienne et les
spectateurs à ce qu'ils attendent encore
des grands discours est ce que c'est ça
qu'on attend d'un homme politique je ne
sais pas si c'est ce qui les attend mais
dans ce que dans ce que vous disiez vous
aviez fort justement indiqué qu'un grand
discours c'est un discours qui nous ont
marqués au point qu'on se souvienne tous
de là où on était au moment où ce
discours a été prononcé c'est une
manière de de situer le grand discours
mais il ya un deuxième conséquence et ça
fait lien avec votre question qui est un
grand discours alter modifie change le
regard que porte à moyen terme les
français les électeurs sur celui qui a
prononcé ce discours donc c'est quelque
chose de lourd d'important et dans la
rupture que vous introduisez avec
l'arrivée de valéry giscard d'estaing
vers des grands discours qui deviennent
davantage des moments de com voir des
moments de pub ou des moments de télé
oui on va retrouvé cet élément là on a
fait un sondage sur les différents
présidents de la cinquième en laissant
de côté ceux qui appartiennent désormais
davantage à l'histoire pour les
françaises terre de gaulle et pompidou
en prenant depuis giscard les différents
présidents et on se rend compte que
finalement les français aujourd'hui
retiennent
jacques chirac comme le président les
ayant le plus marqué ce qui est amusant
cocasse parce que pendant toutes les
années où je suis tombé à cause de
l'irak à cause d'eux et on y arrive la
tête d'hoarau kleiza pas que le 10 mai
pendant toutes les années où je suivais
la popularité de jacques chirac il a été
un président extrêmement impopulaire et
que les français trouvaient quasiment
inutile dans son action distincts
l'intervenant a pas assez à leurs yeux
sur les sur les choses importantes
et pourtant ils ont retenu une chose
quand on leur pose la question celle que
vous venez poser qu'est ce que vous
retenez de jacques chirac ils ont retenu
villepin et moi si vous me demandiez je
pense que comme beaucoup de français de
ma génération un grand discours qui m'a
énormément marqué n'est pas le discours
d'un président de la république c'est le
discours de l'onu de dominique de
villepin en 2003 et ça fait sens avec
ensuite toute l'action de jacques chirac
en tant que président la république ster
que celui dont on se souvenait comme
étant quelqu'un qui n'agissaient pas au
quotidien sur les problèmes des français
sur le chômage sur la croissance sur les
enjeux prioritaires et bien quelques
années après avoir quitté le pouvoir
très peu de temps finalement après avoir
quitté l'elysée eh bien on se souvient
de lui comme étant l'homme qui à travers
certaines postures et pourquoi pas
certains grands discours vous avez parlé
de celui du vel d'hiv aussi et bien
incarner quelque chose avec les
calanques c'est ça ait l'air en face le
grandissait les élèves savent ou si vous
voulez les faits pub ou comme ne marche
pas l'effet pub google lendemain a
grandi le jean dans l'assemblage vouloir
regarder à la loupe si vous voyez que ça
bouge de deux points c'est en général
qu'on est dans la marge d'erreur
statistique ça ne change rien d'accord
en revanche ce qu'un grand discours une
ou une belle intervention peut produire
c'est à plus moyen terme hu à plus long
terme si c'est en cohérence avec la
personnalité politique qui a été
l'auteur de ce grand discours et bien
c'est un regard qui va être modifié
effectivement je vous rejoins c'est
dommage que françois hollande ou nicolas
sarkozy lorsqu'il était président n'ait
pas réussi à tenir ses grands discours
marquant on va selon ses livres est un
petit jeu on a tenté de réduire chacun
de ces grands moments qui appartiennent
parfois l'histoire à une phrase et on
s'est aperçu que généralement un grand
discours c'est une phrase est une phrase
qui marque pratiquement 140 signes sur
twitter si vous voulez qu'on soit
résolument moderne regardez
nationalisme c'est la guerre et c'est un
vieux pays la france d'un vieux
continent comme le mien l'europe qui
vous le dis aujourd'hui
cet adversaire c'est le monde de la
finance
alors le dernier évidemment on va
pouvoir en discuter parce que quand le
discours trahi la ligne politique qui
suit c'est évidemment compliqué à gérer
mais c'est la force du slogan c'est
l'étendard c'est la bannière bien sûr
bien sûr et c'est pourquoi souvent les
grands discours seront prononcés en
période de campagne électorale parce
qu'il résume bien bar une formule ce que
veut entendre la foule qui est venue
applaudir mais vous avez un exemple pour
giscard par exemple puisque tout à
l'heure alain duhamel essayer de sauver
giscard des griffes de general motors
l'un des plus grands discours de giscard
parce qu'il est il a été mis en scène
c'est le discours de verdun sur le doubs
sur le bon choix
puisqu'on était à la veille des
élections sont 18 à francs bourgeois
pour la france on est à la veille des
élections
70,18 législatives et la possibilité
peut-être une cohabitation qui est toute
la question était de savoir que ferait
giscard d'estaing et donc il a fait
monter de manière à six navires qui
ferait cela qu'on se demandait s'il
n'allait pas partir absolument bien sûr
voilà et donc il a fait monter la
pression et tout le monde était
suspendue à la réponse de
du président un public mais c'est un
discours électoral comme le discours du
président sont les deux on peut être
trahi par la diaconie c'est une trace
immense non plus sur le bon choix non la
preuve en allant la chercher mais la
formule le bon choix on l'entend celle
là est resté
mais aussi à un moment où alors là ce
sont plus des discours mais il ya un
moment que je pense reste dans la la
tête des gens longtemps après même quand
il n'y a pas de formules mais il peut y
avoir une formule ce sont les débats
présidentiels de l'entre-deux tours
parce qu'à cette occasion là il ya aussi
souvent une phrase qui reste bon jusqu'à
ce nom mais pas le monopole du coeur etc
pour mitterrand c'était les salles à la
réponse ensuite en hand 80 vous êtes
l'homme du passif quand l'élu dit cet
homme du passé en photo on
peut retrouver pour pratiquement chacun
à chaque fois et aujourd'hui et je crois
alors non pas que les gens se rappellent
forcément la phrase en question mais je
crois que les gens se forge de l'image
des des candidats c'était deux derniers
à chaque fois puisque c'est le duel de
l'entre-deux tours quelque chose de fort
à l'occasion de ce coup de de ce débat
même quel que soit le fond c'est à dire
que sur le personnage sur l'évaluation
du personnage donc forcément d'un futur
président qui va le devenir je pense que
c'est un moment qui est décisif pas pour
le vote qui va venir mais pour l'image
qu'ils auront du futur président donc
vous êtes en train de me dire vous
continuez médias le discours il n'est
pas forcément à la tribune il est
généralement la télé il est devenu il
est détenu vénalité un discours est à
dire que on en parlait tout à l'heure
entre jaurès qui construit des périodes
magnifique avec une rhétorique classique
admirable et l'instinct discours de
paragraphes ajus cours de latin français
grecs comme elles ont bon et est
aujourd'hui ce que peuvent être des
morceaux démission d'abord la langue a
diminué en richesse des 9/10 bon ensuite
il n'y a plus de continuité dans
l'intervention aujourd'hui on a des
fragments de discours dans les
interventions et je pense que c'est à
deux éléments parmi beaucoup d'autres
mais dans l'absence présumée de charisme
ou woods en l'absence d'autorité
naturelle exercée sur son peuple
le fait que au lieu qui est le grand
discours rhétorique vous avez des
fragments ou des poussières
d'intervention je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne se produit pas seulement
l'année mais quand clément cédant
clemenceau prononcer ses grands discours
à l'assemblée ou à la chambre des
députés ils étaient reproduits quasi
intégralement le lendemain dans la
graisse absolue vous avez raison alors
qu'aujourd'hui leur album les jours si
je peux me permettre nicolas sarkozy a
parlé pratiquement tous les jours
françois hollande parle pratiquement
tous les jours c'est un peu c'est un peu
un problème pourquoi nalisation le
présidentielle il faut que d'une
certaine manière qu'elle se fasse rare
et aujourd'hui avec notamment la réforme
du quinquennat il faut bien le dire
c'est pas seulement un problème de
médias il doit être présent tous les
jours et tous les jours il n'a pas à
avancer un discours qui est
particulièrement marge ermi rosen
combien de discours présidentiels
parents que vous avez calculé ça non je
peux calculer quelqu'un à quelqu'un ce
chiffre cette idée non moi je dirais en
tout cas une bonne centaine 110
prise de parole et leur prise de parole
oui oui mais non parce que de sans abri
prononcent des discours et il va à
calais et un discours il va à marseille
un deuxième disque de gaulle faisait ça
oui même moins souvent
quelle différence entre ses discours du
quotidien et un grand discours alors il
faut faire un grand discours il faut
prendre de la hauteur ce qui est un peu
difficile aujourd'hui pour à présent
plus difficile aujourd'hui prendre de la
hauteur fait un discours qui porte une
vision est donc aujourd'hui on a une
vision c'est sortir de l'ambiguïté
sortir demain 18 si ce n'est pas
toujours très simple sans doute mais un
discours de ce type ça se prépare et ça
se prépare dans un moule médiatique dans
un système médiatique on mettra un
signal attention voilà le grand discours
qui arrivent et donc on donnera rendez
vous aux médias pour remarquer à quel
point ce discours on grandit en moi le
prototype du très grand discours préparé
exactement comme vous dites c'est à dire
à la fois scénarise et annoncés à
l'avancé trouvant la forme qu'il faut
c'est kennedy à berlin quand qu'un
ailier est à berlin je suis un berlinois
et s'est produit un effet absolument
prodigieux il a l'histoire la salle
histoire c'est le dentier kiki qui a
écouté et intériorisé ce qu'ils disaient
ce qui est compliqué s'agissant de
françois hollande c'est que justement
son image et celle de quelqu'un qui
manque d'autorité qui manque de hauteur
qui n'a pas un cap bien clair et donc
bien sûr vous avez raison de dire que ça
lui manquait que ce serait précieux pour
lui de pouvoir se doter de cela mais le
problème c'est qu'il est tellement
inaudible aujourd'hui que sans un
prétexte ou sans une raison à un moment
un moment sans sens berlin sans le point
est rien à faire puisque quentin kennedy
est allé à berlin il y avait une raison
bien précise
il aurait le plus grand mal françois
hollande à ce que son discours ne fasse
pas petit parce que justement
aujourd'hui en tout cas et depuis qu'il
a été élu il a cette image là par
ailleurs souvent dans les grands
discours une accélération il ya
l'acceptation d'une rupture y quand on
pense à jacques chirac en 95 vous l'avez
évoqué sur le vel d'hiv il envoie d'une
certaine manière un bras d'honneur à
beaucoup de gens dans son propre camp ça
n'a pas certains à gauche n'ont pas
apprécié et beaucoup à droite n'ont pas
aimé ce qu'il considérait comme un
discours dénigrant la france et
étendant la repentance pour citer des
propos qui ont été tenus à l'époque est
ce que françois hollande aujourd'hui
serait capable de tenir un discours de
l'arrivage du rupture entre yves mayeux
rupture de rupture a forcément parce que
en janvier il a su trouver alors c'est
pas un grand discours parce que c'est
une courte intervention il y avait le
mail a su oui mais ça prouve qu'il en
est capable oui et ça prouve que au fond
le grand discours c'est la rencontre
entre un talent et un événement un
moment et d'une manière ou d'une autre
une rupture si françois hollande
aujourd'hui
préparer un grand discours sur son
projet face qu'on manque en france un
projet de société bon et que il
attendait l'occasion qui devienne un
symbole pour être porteur de ce discours
à ce moment là je crois qu'il ne serait
pas inaudible oui c'est possible il
faudrait il faudrait le moment tout prix
mais rien de préparé le projet et de le
sortir au moment il ya quand même eu un
grand discours au moins et d'ailleurs
vous le signaler votre votre film dans
ce quinquennat il a été prononcé par le
premier ministre après les attentats de
janvier
il y avait
trois couleurs un moment qui me sont
venus à l'esprit
trois couleurs de ces trois policiers
ces deux policiers nationaux et cette
policière municipale elle représentait
ils représentaient la diversité des
parcours
et des origines trois couleurs
différentes
trois parcours mais trois français trois
serviteurs
de l'état
et
devant les cercueils
aux côtés
de leurs familles il n'y avait que trois
couleurs celles du drapeau national si
au fond ça le plus beau message je vous
avais dit ici au mois d'avril ma fierté
comme chacun d'entre vous d'être
français il ya quelque chose qui nous a
tous renforcer
après ces événements et après les
marches de cette fin de semaine je crois
que nous le sentons tous c'est plus que
jamais la fierté d'être français ne
l'oublions jamais
il faut signaler que l'hémicycle est
debout l'assemblée entière est debout
droite et gauche confondues à ce
moment-là vous disiez l'émotion tout à
l'heure c'est la marque d'un grand
discours c'est la marque d'un grand
discours et ça s'inscrit finalement dans
une tradition parce que sont prononcés
les plus grands discours de la
république dans l'hémicycle sous la
troisième république
avant
re jaurès clemenceau brillant herriot et
c est là on s'inscrit dans cette
continuité
et finalement les plus grands designers
ont donc nous pompidou le duel entre le
268 entre pompidou et mitterrand est
tout à fait exemplaire à cet égard et
les grands discours finalement qu'on va
retenir c'est quoi c'est par exemple
simone veil en 74 c'est robert badinter
en 80 et je pense que le lieu du grand
discours c'est plutôt l'assemblée
colisée mais ses frappes et pardonnez
moi le président la république il a pris
la parole quatre fois cette semaine là
et on retient premier ministre oui mais
je crois que le bis par le discours de
manuel valls pour moi c'est le plus beau
discours politique que j'ai entendue
depuis au moins dix ans est d'abord je
trouve qu'ils prenaient vraiment aux
tripes quand on l'écouté ensuite il y
avait un comportement exemplaire de
l'assemblée alors là c'est pas depuis
dix ans et depuis un siècle et il y
avait une émotion physique qui
s'explique à la fois par la force de
l'événement par les qualités d'orateur
d'éloquence incontestable de manuel
valls mais par le fait et c'est ça qui
je pense était à l'origine de son
inspiration pas c'était vraiment un
discours valls c'est sait que c'est le
problème qui ressent au fond de lui-même
c'est c'est le catalan devenu français
pour qui être français c'est quelque
chose de tellement formidable que chacun
des mots qui prononçait ce n'est vrai
juste c'est rarissime dans un discours
donc c'est authentique au bon moment la
bonne à weeds et danser concerne les
authentiques au bon moment dans un
contexte exceptionnel je sais pas si on
a bien mesuré l'impact qu'avait eu ces
événements du 11 janvier si sur ce
qu'ont ressenti les français c'est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que sur tous
les indicateurs que l'on peut suivre de
perception du moral de confiance en
l'avenir de fierté d'être français de
sentiment qu'on serait en déclin ou pas
il ya eu un moment où pardon de le dire
comme ça grâce à ces attentats à la
suite de ces attentats il ya eu une
fierté collective on a vu un bon sur
tout ce que j'ai indiqué le moral la
confiance la fierté d'être français le
fait qu'ils aient un divorce monstre eux
qui existe dans ce pays depuis 20 ans
entre et qui s'accentue entre les
français et leurs élites qu'elles soient
politiques journalistes quelle qu'elle
soit sondeurs là à un moment donné il ya
une parenthèse une forme de parenthèse
enchantée où les français se sentent est
fier et où effectivement à linghem à la
raison c'est tout à fait manuel valls
est à dire ce que ce qu'il dit est est
quelque chose il avait ancré il avait
mis des marqueurs il le portait en lui
depuis bien avant tout cela il avait
même été critiqué et moqué dans son camp
à gauche pour cette attitude là
justement et donc c'est effectivement un
très grand discours et vous avez raison
de souligner sa discours deux premiers
ministres comme celui d'il parlant je
parlais tout à l'heure et pas un
discours de président cela dit françois
hollande a été aussi très fortement
apprécié par les français dans toutes
ses prises de position et pour être
complet même nicolas sarkozy non retour
est assez critiquée dans l'opinion a été
appréciée pour la posture qu'il a eu
même si les gens ont regretté qu'il y
avait un peu jouer des coudes dans les
manifs mais il ya un discours de
président un discours de premier
ministre un discours de président
discours de militaire étrangère c'est
pas la même chose manuel valls il engage
pas la france maintient ce niveau là qui
dans qu'il a tenus c'est ce que c'est ce
que je vous entendent abaisser par
définition c'est d'un discours
consensuel il répond à une préoccupation
majeure
aujourd'hui c'est en étant en crise
identitaire la question c'est quelle est
notre identité et là il répond voilà
quelle est votre identité donc on veut
c'est un grand discours
c'est pour moi c'est un grand discours
oui oui c'est surtout de mon histoire
qui nous le dira s'il va rester dans les
mémoires en tout cas ce qui est sûr ce
qui remet
dans l'esprit des français je trouve
l'importance du verbe à ce moment là
autour de ces mots de valls les français
reconnaissent une vraie dignité aussi à
la classe politique qui sait comme comme
vous lisiez qui sait qui c'est vraiment
bien bien comportés on peut dire pendant
ces moments là et ça donne peut-être
l'espoir effectivement que à des
événements - triste que ça
la parole politique peut encore avoir
une portée importante et touchent et
touché deux les français je vais faire
le chafouin je mettre un bémol ça n'a
pas duré cet état d'esprit ça n'a pas
duré mais ça n'a pas d'incidence durable
sur les popularités et c est ce que ça
veut dire que ça ne laisse pas trace
pour autant c'est pas la même chose si
on prend le cas de françois hollande
avant ou après ces événements sa
popularité dont elle a monté un instant
et elle est redescendue tout en
frémissant un peu bon mais enfin ça n'a
pas changé le fond des choses mais en
revanche sur la considération qu'on a
pour lui c'est d'ailleurs ce son statut
sur l'image de son statut ça a changé
quelque chose pour moi c'est la maman
dans la tête des français il est devenu
le président ans c'est quand même
dommage sur françois hollande et sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique mais
surtout les gouvernants parce que
laurent bazin raison on est quand même
dans une situation où pour les raisons
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
français étaient prêts à deux nouveaux à
croire et ça fait ch clutch parce que
pendant les semaines qui ont suivi on
est revenu à des considérations qui
étaient des considérations qui manquait
de souffle qui manqué d'envergure vous
avez raison de dire que il ya eu un
avant et un après au sens où à un moment
donné les français se sont dits ce
président que l'on juge si médiocre et
bien il est capable d'avoir une hauteur
une vraie compétence à un moment fort
lourd est important
mais je ne suis quand on regarde
effectivement sa popularité avant après
elle est retombée en deux mois
exactement au niveau calamiteux qui
étaient les siens avant donc je ne sais
pas si c'est pas une occasion manquée
mais vous dites qualitativement vous
confirmer ce que les gens
oui il ya eu un moment où les gens se
sont dit les hauts niveaux mais
aujourd'hui je ne pense toujours pas
donc est-ce que ça va renaître on manque
de tribun ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il
faut des grands hommes pour faire de
grands discours
pas voir des tribuns savoir des tribunes
et aujourd'hui va barder tribune
télévisée il y avait ils viennent à la
chambre des députés il y avait
l'assemblée il y avait les meetings
aujourd'hui ça compte beaucoup moi et
puis les meetings sont faits finalement
pour qui sont faits pour les médias ils
sont faits pour la petite formule qui va
être reprise au 20h d'ailleurs ont
distribué aux journalistes la feuille du
discours avec stabilo boss et souligné
la phrase à reprendre la reprenne ou
pains et la parole comme la tienne passe
par autre chose aujourd'hui elle passe
effectivement parlé dans la télévision
elle passe par les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui mais vous le regrettez vous
pas une bonne foi moment je regrette
rien j'ai l'idée on parlait tout à
l'heure du sondage sur les anciens
présents de la république avec cette
valeur nostalgique que l'on que l'on
porte vers s'est présentée à lui l'idée
que c'était mieux avant non gérons on
s'adapte aux technologies des hommes
politiques se sont adaptés à la radio
ils se sont adaptés et je vais vous le
dire autrement alors christian delporte
et les autres est ce que est ce que ça
appauvrit le discours politique ah ça
c'est autre chose
c'était le fond de la question et dcs
qu'on a appauvri la politique en
réduisant son espace où son espace de
discours le discours c'est sûr il ya
aucun doute sur le fait que les outils
lozère est normalien aujourd'hui par
exemple et puis et puis alain l'a dit
nous on est obligé on est obligé des
politiques on est obligé d'être repris
sur les chaînes infos dans un délai très
court tout est formaté pour internet
évidemment que c'est d'abord et après il
ya plus de prise de parole qu'il n'y en
avait avant les marges - me dit 20
depuis le début de la pauvreté du
vocabulaire politique ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui ça commence et notamment
dans les années 80 où les hommes
politiques eux mêmes ont volontairement
appauvri lors leur vocabulaire pour se
faire comprendre des plus grands nombres
de kabila ou des idées ou du
raisonnement - fois ensemble oui
oui parce que derrière les mots il y a
des idées plus on appauvrit les mots
plus on appauvrit les idées et
aujourd'hui 11 ans d'une période
évidemment alain duhamel l'évoquait ou
au manque de vision politique je
dors encore dans les années 70 sont ceux
projetés à 20 ans 30 ans aujourd'hui on
se projette à six mois est ce qui est
terrible est liée au disco ou plutôt à
l'absence de discours c'est que on
manque de projet au moment où on en a
besoin plus que jamais puisque les
français doutent quand les français
doutent il faut bien leur donner des
réponses et ses réponses ça doit passer
par des grands discours parce que tout
est multi intervention je veux dire
philippot à bfm tous les matins ce sont
des des des tout-petits marqueur
politiciens mais c'est le contraire d'un
projet présenté est ce qui manque aux
politiques ou plurielle c'est qu'ils en
aient au moins trois ou quatre parce que
c'est une chose a relevé au passage très
souvent les grands discours donc les
grands orateurs vont par paire ou par
trio cyr pour qui un très grand 10 e
cathy muller et les autres voilà pour
que clemenceau soit formidable il faut
que poincaré ce qu on a complètement
oublié soit un très grand orateur parce
que ils se répondent ils se battent
jaurès contre clemenceau c'était
prodigieux
l'hallali l'ironie terrible 2010 avait
rassemblé mitterrandie d'abord
mitterrand contre pompidou c'était des
très grands moments
car oui le non s'est il il faut qu'ils
soient plusieurs maillots faux hollande
sarkozy
ça pourrait oui mais voilà ressent plus
maintenant j'attends de voir enfin sur
les petites phrases le
la technique de politique aujourd'hui
effectivement de communiqué
perpétuellement par par par signes 140
signes sur twitter mais de fait des
messages sur facebook là je me tourne
peut-être plus si man c'est la question
c'est est-ce que c'est pas non plus le
mode de consommation des citoyens
aujourd'hui de consommer des citoyens
consommateurs de la politique qui de
cette manière là bien évidemment bien ce
bien sûr bien sûr vous avez raison mais
les citoyens consomment de la chaîne
info il consomme du tweet il consomme
tout cela mes dessins sont de retour dit
c'est bien d'écouter l'offre ça ne veut
pas dire que la demande doivent être
totalement dictée
papa parce que souhaitent les
téléspectateurs ou les où il a ses
moyens d'écouter la demande bien
d'écouter la demande mais l'offre
politique soit dit merci d'avoir une ag
c'est tout à fait ça et sinon on est
constamment à la remorque de ce qui
attendrait les français les citoyens et
puis un marqueur fort comme peut l'être
un grand discours comme celui de manuel
valls qu'on a vu tout à l'heure il
n'était pas demandée dans les sondages
en amont si vous voulez ça veut pas dire
qu'une fois que ce discours a été
effectué et ça n'a pas eu un impact
considérable sur l'image de manuel valls
il me semblait problème en ce moment des
de l'absence de grands discours c'est
l'absence de rencontre entre un
événement dramatique un orateur a une
fonction bien sûr mais c'est aussi un
phénomène qui est générale qui est à la
fois
d'approfondissement de
d'appauvrissement du discours politique
et en même temps de fragmentation du
discours politique je crois que donc il
ya un grand discours je dis pas qu'il
faut être interminable mais je pense
qu'il faut vraiment du temps et ça se
retrouve même dans les émissions
politiques il faut faire sans on en 40
minutes minimum oui il y en a plus de 40
minutes tout seul et le phénomène de la
fragmentation si vous regardez bien ce
que vous faites comment ce ça se passe
dans la formation continue et et
ailleurs enfin dans la formation tout
court avant il pouvait y avoir dans les
grandes circonstances des longues
séquences aujourd'hui tout est fragmenté
même si vous prenez une émission
politique vous aurez une succession de
6,7 hui séquence donc vous n'aurez à
aucun moment ce qui fait l'unification
et ce qui peut être porter le cas
échéant si les circonstances le talent
deux dindes un grand moment pour
l'instant c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas j'ai une question pour
finir christian delporte peut-être
si vous pouviez nous recommander la re
lecture ou leur visionnage ou le
visionnage d'un grand discours plus ou
moins oubliés lequel serait-il
le grand discours à ré écouter
le discours de mendès-france 155 sur la
démocratie parce qu'il a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de résonance c'est à
l'assemblée non à evreux et où
il part de la démocratie où il parle de
la jeunesse et où il parle de la vérité
en politique ça peut être très utile
aujourd'hui à la nuit à même le discours
de chaban écrit par son équipe mais
néanmoins porté par lui sur la nouvelle
société quand il a été investi à
l'assemblée merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir été sur sur ce plateau
évidemment le débat continue sur les
réseaux sociaux en 140 signes ou plus le
mail de l'émission également pouvez nous
écrire ça s'inscrit en bas de votre
écran la semaine prochaine claire
barsacq ouvre un autre grand dossier
tout à fait différent c'est celui du
recyclage des matières plastiques on
sait que l'écologie et du développement
durable c'est important pour vous n'êtes
pas là dessus non plus au bout de vos
surprises
à très vite sur public sénat
oui